the buck stops with me I shouldn't
oughta let that happen and but once the
punt team was out there there was two
choices use your last timeout or take a
penalty and I decided to take a pony in
that team eight minutes left yes yes
would that have been better communicated
to everybody on the TV show that further
evidence that the New England Patriots
reside in the brains of every coach and
every team they face big cat it was from
Sunday afternoon seven minutes left in
the game 17 point deficit Freddy
kitchens decided we're going for it no
matter what we're not going to punt he
decided that before the drive started
so when fourth and 11 rolled around the
punt team went out on the field he
deliberately took a penalty in lieu of
using a timeout so he could go for it on
fourth and 16 instead and he admits on
Monday he failed to communicate to
anyone that he wasn't going to punt
there and this is kind of like the
reverse patch Shurmur from a couple of
weeks ago when Shermer did punt in that
spot I think kitchens was determined not
to punt in that spot the key is you got
to tell somebody and this gets back to
what kind of a learning curve are we
gonna tolerate from a new head coach
because you can look at this big hat and
say this isn't part of your learning
curve this is something you either
understand or you don't this is basic
human communication you can be coaching
Pop Warner and understand that you need
to tell the other people on the
sidelines we're gonna go for it on
fourth down on this Drive don't put the
punt team on the field at any time yeah
it's coaching the little things and
communication is a big part of that and
it's similar to the Matt Nagy
conversation going into the Freddy
kitchens conversation dysfunctional
teams do dysfunctional things and you
see this with Freddy kitchens not having
a grasp on you know communicating with
his special teams with his offense
that's just crazy to me
would you ever see a you know competent
head coach doing something like this
absolutely not and I think you bring up
a great point
the learning curve especially in the NFL
now teams expect to win right away
you know the the
talk in the offseason about the Browns
and the talent they've added and what
they're gonna do it's it's got to be
absolutely maddening to watch something
like this happen do you think Mike there
is and we never talk about another man's
job let's just let's preface it with
this we never talk about another man's
job do you think there's a possibility
the Browns could move on from Freddie
kitchens after only one year well I
think they should consider it but I
don't think it's a strong possibility
because the Browns are still so bruised
by the fact that they made too rash of a
decision with guys like Rob Kazinsky and
they had too many coaches they ran off
early in Jimmy Haslam's tenure it's
almost like they're determined to not
continue that so they kept Hugh Jackson
longer than they should have and I think
they may keep Freddie kitchens longer
than they should have look this was an
experiment this was a calculated risk
they didn't want to hire a new head
coach and keep kitchens as offensive
coordinator and then have kitchens
continue to do as well as you did last
year and lose him after this season so
what the hell just making the head coach
I mad that argument if you're concerned
they're gonna lose him after this year
because he's working so well with Baker
Mayfield just make him the head coach
but you have to be willing to admit
defeat that's the key if it just didn't
work right you lined up all the the
chemicals and you put them in the test
tubes and you lit the Bunsen burner and
it blew up you got to be able to declare
it a failure and move on and and this
whole thing about I'm learning as I go
that's just not an acceptable
explanation to me you either have it or
you don't I feel bad for him because a
year ago this morning big cat a year ago
he was the running backs coach in
Cleveland minding his own business they
fire huge acts and they fire Todd Haley
next thing you know he's the offensive
coordinator next thing you know he's
doing well enough to be considered for a
head coach he's never been groomed to be
a head coach he's been thrust into this
job with no preparation the question is
how much time does he get to learn the
job on the fly and I you know a fully
functioning team would say not very much
here's an idea what if the Browns keep
Freddie kitchens keep met his current
head coaching salary make him the
offensive coordinator then go out and
hire a head coach so just demote him
in-house I like that I like that I think
contractually I'd have a hard time
pulling it off he'd probably have the
ability to say I'll just take my money
and leave but that's in hindsight they
should have kept me as the offensive
coordinator and they should have hired
somebody else to be the head coach
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports